today on the matt walsh show the
washington post has come up with a new
innovation to account for all the
non-white people who are trump
supporters
they're calling it multi-racial
whiteness yes we'll have to figure out
what that is today also five headlines
including
the media hurries to provide publicity
and attention to the supposed right-wing
militias who are
we're told gathering in state capitals
across the country the funny thing is
that
some of them don't seem to be very
right-wing so we'll talk about that and
our daily cancellation we'll cancel a
public health expert who insist that
it is healthy and wise to exercise
outdoors with a mask on
is there any truth to that we'll find
out today all that and more today on the
matte wall show
before we go any further today quick
word important word from our friends at
lifelock
you know it's it's never been more
important to protect your online data
especially when you think about all the
new tactics that the
thieves are using to steal your data and
a new tactic for stealing your credit
card and personal information has
recently been discovered
this new web skimming attack or
e-skimming injects malicious code into a
compromised ecommerce website's checkout
process that
pulls your order information to display
it on a fake checkout page that steals
your information so
you know when you're buying stuff online
is the kind of thing you have to worry
about
and it's uh it's difficult on your own
to detect this sort of thing to be aware
of it
and that's why it's so important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives every day
we put our information at risk on the
internet
and you could just simply miss many of
the risks to your identity if you're
just monitoring your credit
looking at your bank account the kind of
things that are good to do but it's not
it's not enough
that's why you need life luck lifelock
will do all the things you can't do
lifelock is a leader in identity theft
protection
lifelock detects a wide range of ident
of identity threats like your
uh social security number being for sale
on the dark web and if they detect that
your information has been compromised
they'll send you an alert and if god
forbid something does happen
then they also have identity restoration
specialists who are on staff and there
to help you so you get
you get help on both ends of this
problem no one can prevent all identity
theft or monitor all transactions at all
businesses but lifelock can see threats
that you might miss on your own join now
and save up to 25 percent off your first
year at lifelock.com
walsh that's lifelock.com walsh for 25
off what do you do with someone who is
seemingly
unreachable i mean the sort of person
who holds a position defends it
vigorously and remains
totally impervious to counter arguments
and contrary
evidence the person who couldn't
possibly be more certain of the
rightness of his views and also couldn't
possibly have less
reason to be certain how do you engage
with this with someone who
absolutely refuses to be persuaded
someone who
hangs on to their original assumptions
and beliefs and simply ignores
everything that contradicts it
contradicts it or else incorporates the
contradictory information into their
world view in an entirely ad hoc and
arbitrary way
it quickly feels pointless to engage
with them right it feels like you're
trying to
i don't know explain the color green to
a man who's been blind since birth it's
just it's just not clicking with them
they can't
comprehend what you're telling them or
what makes it all the more frustrating
really is that
they refuse in this case to comprehend
it now
what do you do when the whole country
seems to be filled with people like this
what happens then i suppose what happens
is well everything we're seeing
happening right now it's why talk of
unity is pointless and will go nowhere i
mean how do you
unify with people like this people like
for example the writer of a new op-ed in
the washington post
christina beltran the piece which has
attracted much attention in recent days
is titled here's what it's titled to
understand trump's support
we must think in terms of multiracial
whiteness
yes multiracial whiteness which is i
imagine quite similar
to beautiful ugliness hot coldness
wealthy poverty similar in the sense
that these are all non-sequiturs it
makes no sense
so here's some of what christina beltran
has to say she says
the trump administration's
anti-immigration anti-civil rights
stance has made it easy to classify the
president's loyalists
as a huma as a homogeneous mob of white
nationalists
but take a look at the fbi's poster
poster showing people wanted in the
insurrection assault on the u.s capitol
among among the many white faces are a
few that are clearly latino or
african-american
yes white faces that are clearly latino
or african-american
white faces that are african-american
this reminds me of when i stood in line
at the cinnabon alongside many
skinny people who were clearly obese in
fact based on my diet you may say that
i'm i'm the reverse i'm an obese person
who is skinny you know
these things can happen anyway
continuing it says such diversity
highlights the fact that president
trump's share of the latino vote in
november
in november actually rose over 2016
notwithstanding years of incendiary
rhetoric targeting mexicans and other
latino communities
yes trump's voters and his mob are
disproportionately white but one of the
most unsettling exit poll data points of
the 201 election
was that a quarter of a third to a third
of latino voters voted to re-elect trump
and while the vast majority of latinos
an overwhelming majority of
african-american voters supported the
biden-harris ticket and were crucial to
its success many black and brown voters
have family and friends
who fervently back the mag of policy
agenda including its delusions and
conspiracy theories
one of the organizers of the stop the
steel movement is ali alexander a trump
supporter who identifies as black and
arab
the chairman of the neo-fascist proud
boys is enrique torrio
a latino raised in miami's little havana
who identifies as afro-cuban
so here's the problem all laid out right
people like beltran have decided that
supporters of trump and his policies are
a homogeneous mob of white nationalists
that's the position they've staked out
it's the assumption they've made
it was never based on any evidence it
never had anything to do with the actual
reality of the situation
but this is what they decided and then
comes the counter
the evidence to the contrary the fact
that as is acknowledged here there are
plenty of people who support trump and
his policies and yet are not white how
do you account for that
now it's true that th that the fact that
some not
non-white people support trump doesn't
in and of itself prove that trump
is not racist or that most of his
supporters aren't but it is a point that
must be explained
it does throw a wrench into the works
right if you're on the left it's a piece
of data
that that the original theory doesn't
predict
or account for it so what do you do
about it
do you stop and assess do you
re-evaluate your position do you strive
to develop a more nuanced understanding
no of course not instead you do this
from the piece it says
rooted in america's ugly history of
white supremacy indigenous
white supremacy indigenous dispossession
and anti-blackness
multiracial whiteness is an ideology
invested in the unequal distribution of
land wealth power and privilege
it continues multiracial whiteness
reflects an understanding of whiteness
as a political color
a political color and not simply a
racial identity
a discriminatory worldview in which
feelings of freedom and belonging are
produced
through the persecution and
dehumanization of others
for voters who see the very act of
acknowledging one's racial identity as
itself racist
the politics of multiracial whiteness
reinforces the desired approach to
colorblind individualism in the politics
of multiracial whiteness anyone can join
the maga movement
and engage in the wild freedom of
unbridled rage and conspiracy theories
america's racial divide is not simply
between whites and non-whites
thinking in terms of multiracial
whiteness helps us recognize that much
of today's political rift
is a division between those who are
drawn to and remain invested in
a politics of whiteness and those who
seek something better okay now
before we analyze this further there's
one other quick passage from this piece
just sort of dropped into the middle
which is true
it actually undermines the point that's
being made it says if you want to speak
spanish and celebrate a quinceaner
quinceanera in your family go ahead if
you want to be a proud boy be a proud
boy
trump doesn't care as long as you love
him
he'll love you yes that part
right there that part that is a correct
summation of trump and his approach to
people that's actually true
love him and he'll love you hate him and
he'll hate you
you know in fact well it's more love him
and who love you criticize him and it'll
hate you doesn't matter if you actually
hate him you criticize him at all he'll
ate you
i'm not going to pretend that this is
the best way to be or the best way to
live but it's clearly how trump
approaches things
then it means he's not racist because
his decision to hate or love you has
nothing to do with your race ethnicity
sexual orientation
or anything else any of your identifying
characteristics
that doesn't matter to him what matters
to him is how you feel about him and
what you
say about him period that's all
say what you want about that disposition
but you can't call it racist
because race has nothing to do with it
the writer of the article notices this
about trump's and takes note of it
acknowledges it but then proceeds right
along with her original thesis
that thesis as we recall is that trump
and his supporters are all racist white
supremacists
what does she do about the fact that
many of trump supporters aren't even
whites
well not to worry she can just turn them
into sort of honorary white people
they're white people politically they
engage in the politics of whiteness
whatever that means
notice of course the outrageous over the
top in your face
racism on display here i mean this is
the irony that we're all accustomed by
now
accustomed to by now the people who rail
against racism tend to be the greatest
examples of what they're pretending to
oppose
and here she is equating whiteness with
evil
really her point is that is that a black
person who is evil and bigoted and bad
in her view is really white because of
that
this is just about the most racist
possible view a person can hold and
express
and she's given a column in the
washington post to express it
it goes without saying though of course
this does not go the other way
a white person who has all the correct
views by the writer's standards
does not get to lay claim to a
multi-racial blackness
you know they don't get to be to be
considered a black face that is white
the rachel dolezals of the world are
cast aside despite the fact
that they're simply adopting and living
by the ideas and the philosophy
expressed in this article
but you know that's the great thing
about being impervious to
reality and unwilling to abandon your
original assumptions
you don't have to worry about being
consistent you don't even have to
concern yourself with basic coherence
you can just make up your worldview as
you go
and that is how the writer of this
article has chosen to live and sadly
very sadly she is far from alone
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well today is a day of mourning for me
this is a tough weekend
ravens lose to the bills didn't even
score a touchdown
i think the final score was the finals
go 21-3 or something i blocked it out of
my mind already
i just zoned out terrible
terrible stuff and you know you know
what you know what the thing is though
it's not fair
it's not fair lamar jackson goes down
with a concussion
you know justin tucker the great field
goal kicker of the ravens
um you know he's going to be the hall of
fame the most accurate kicker of all
time he misses two
this is two kicks it is not fair i say
not fair in fact what i here's what i
think
mike pence needs to decertify the
results of this game
it is unconstitutional illegitimate
calling on mike pence to do the right
thing and decertify these results
we'll see we'll see if he has the
courage he has the courage to act
in this moment of crisis for our nation
all right um number one we've been told
about the right-wing militias who are
going to be storming the capitals across
the country
well one such group showed up at the
michigan state capitol and they held up
i guess a press conference okay and the
media
also showed up to cover this press
conference but we're gonna watch we're
gonna listen and watch this because
uh they're they're just some odd details
about this
right-wing militia maybe you can pick up
on some of it but uh here it is listen
right-wing militias they are the
antibodies not the disease that is
destroying our country
the disease is a country run by two
political parties that do not care about
you
so deeply deeply so deeply and
centurious
with corporations that they're
indistinguishable from each other
[Music]
a government that spent six months
debating whether to give their own
people six hundred dollars
but only 24 hours to unanimously agree
to give billions of dollars to foreign
tyrannical governments and corporations
a government that has bombed villages
overseas my entire life
for my supposed safety here this is a
call for unity
for all of american people that realize
the true threat
against us to come together
um yeah okay so a few things there
and he and he goes on it goes on for
like another minute and he he also
mentions you know
he's speaking i don't think it was in
that clip he's he's speaking out on
behalf of
of the mothers have lost children to
police brutality he mentions that
uh among other things now so a few
things number one
you've got a few yahoos standing in
front of the michigan state capitol
uh with their you know with with their
their their gear on and everything
and uh and and then you get this swarm
of media people
cameras in their face i mean this guy
who is this guy i don't know who this
guy is
right he's holding a press conference
and the whole media shows up to cover it
why are they covering it how is it
whatever this guy is saying
uh why is that news
well i mean you can arrive at your own
conclusions
but i'll just say this the media is not
giving all of this attention
to these people because they want to
quell
unrest or because they want less
of this that's not how that works
if they really wanted less of it then
they would just starve these people of
attention
i mean that's how if you want the people
that were at the michigan state capital
if you want them to go away then what
you do is just ignore them you let them
stay out stand outside and you just
ignore them
and if they're giving a press conference
he's giving a speech that he's reading
off his phone
you ignore it and then he would
eventually they would go home because
they're there for the attention right
well the media knows that but uh but no
they want more of it because it's great
for ratings
and also it's great ideologically for
them because they could try to put all
this on the right but the other
interesting thing is that
okay you got this guy you heard some of
what he said there um and he's he's uh
he's carrying a rainbow flag a gay pride
flag the person right next to him is
wearing a blm
hoodie so you've got a guy with a beat
with a rainbow
gay pride flag someone with with blm
gear
and he's ranting about you know
corporations and police brutality
he says a few things in there that if
you're on the right you might agree with
and then a few things if you're on the
left you agree with and a few things
that probably everybody agree with and
you know the stuff
about uh you know they they're not doing
enough to help people during the
shutdown
okay most people agree with that so it's
a general sentiment
but how is this right wing is my
question
you could make an argument for being
left one you could make an argument for
it being neither it's not really in the
binary as we like to say these days
i don't see right wing a guy with a
rainbow flag standing next to a blm
person
talking about police brutality that to
me is not what i imagine when i imagine
right-wing militia
you know maybe it's just me all right
number two look
i give the media a hard time i just did
there again but the truth is we we do
need the media um
we need them to fight for truth and
justice
uh to ask the the tough questions
uh to get down to what really matters i
mean these are the firefighters right in
the media these are the people
who uh fight the fires and if the fire
is
is falsehood they come in with their
hoses of truth
and save the day and i think
that's what we see in this cbs interview
with camila harris i think we see a lot
of that it's just it's really admirable
stuff so let's let's listen and we had
to ask about that fashion choice
surely a first for a vice president the
converse chuck taylor sneakers
the chucks i gotta tell you when you
walked in
i checked out is she wearing them you're
not
wearing your chucks today no what is the
story
it became a story i've always worn
shocks
it's my casual it's my casual go-to
you know grew up with chucks i just love
them they're comfortable
i can attest there is a several closets
full of them
he's exaggerating yeah this wasn't just
something that she started doing
on the campaign and when i met her it
was chucks and jeans when she met the
kids
and what did it say to you she's down to
earth
people ask me all the time like what she
really like i said she's shockingly
normal
i think that is really an extension of
who she really is
an extension of who she really is are
her shoes
what did it say to you when you saw her
wearing those shoes
first of all the honest answer from any
man
if you're asking a man what is your why
your wife's
shoe choice what does it say to you the
honest answer for any man is it says
nothing to me i've never noticed
okay i i've never noticed the shoes that
she's wearing in my life ever
for all i know for all i know my wife
wears chuck taylors every day i have no
idea
it's just it's not the kind of thing you
notice as a man or care about
we're supposed to believe when they
first met he saw those chuck taylors and
he said now she's down to earth
this is the woman of my dreams and those
chuck taylors
oh just it just became how did the chuck
how did uh camilla harris's
shoe choice become a story it just
developed organically right
now became a story because the media
made it into a story nobody else cares
the media is obsessed with this this is
this is like the 15th
uh profile they've done of camila
harris's shoes
at least if they were interesting shoes
maybe if she was wearing like
you know disco platform shoes or
something i could see it
but not this and by the way also today
from the media i saw this headline
the headline was all the times joe
biden's love for ice cream melted
our hearts now in fairness this was from
e
online you know the e the entertainment
channel so you don't ex really expect
hard-hitting journalism from them
but even that i mean compare the way the
media is in love with the fact that joe
biden eats ice cream all the time
and compare that with the fact that you
know with with donald trump eating fast
food
there's there's we never got any
headlines about
all the times uh uh donald trump's love
for big macs
melted our heart no in that case it was
oh this
gross disgusting man with his unhealthy
eating
making a mockery of the obesity epidemic
so i'll get ready for a lot of this kind
of thing number three alexandria cortez
is putting her foot down once and for
all uh so you better listen up because
she is serious this time here she is
listen
what we saw last week was not
just a violent coup attempt
um but we als also saw a dereliction of
duty
and a betrayal of our country and a
betrayal
of the oath that we swear and that
is why i have demanded the resignations
of senators ted cruz
senators josh hawley um majority leader
republican majority or rather republican
minority leader in the house
mccarthy kevin mccarthy yeah
and you know and i will counter that by
saying i demand the resignations of
alexandria
cortez uh joe biden
camille harris mark zuckerberg
colonel sanders i just i demand
everyone's resignation
um yeah this is we can make jokes about
it of course is just this this impotent
i i demand the resignations of i demand
the resignations of
of all the republicans in congress i
demand it
i want your resignations on my desk
tonight
uh so we could laugh at the impotence of
that but but really this is just another
example of
you you look at how the left has reacted
to uh uh one example of
right-wingers writing okay we've had
we had precisely one example of that
period in memory and this is how they
react to it
you know they're they're shutting
everything down demanding resignations
of everybody
donald trump has kicked off twitter they
impeached him
you know just uh wiping out
without millions of conservative
accounts
they've occupied dc with the military
this is how they react to one
on the left now compare that to how the
right reacted
to months and months and months of left
wing writing
nothing they didn't do anything
and they had the power to do things they
were in a position of power they did
absolutely nothing
so if you understand the difference
between the left and right between
really democrats and republicans
that's it right there one example of
of right-wingers rioting um a small
by the way a small percentage of the
people that were at the rally engaging
in this behavior
and what the democrats do they just shut
everything down
occupy the city impeach everything
right they go absolutely nuclear
response to it and on republicans
very very tolerant and patient you you
know if you're on the left you can just
riot
write all you want we don't want
overstep bounds we don't want to do
anything
you know donald trump in fairness he did
he did tweet law and order in all caps
he tweeted that many times
and conservatives made excuses for that
they said what else do you expect him to
do he's only the president
he can't do anything else so he's you
know he's just trying to respect be
respectful and
what do you think what do you let me ask
you what do you think joe biden is going
to do
if this becomes a semi-trend of
of of small pockets of uh you know trump
supporters or people that at least could
be
at least they can claim our trump trump
supporters rioting or engaging this kind
of baby
if this becomes even a semi trend we
don't even have to talk about hundreds
of riots like we had on the left
if there are even just a few of them
through the first
few months of of biden's tenure how do
you think biden's going to react to that
or at least how do you think the biden
administration is going to react to that
i mean they will be occupying cities
they're going to move the military in
they're going to come down with an irfs
they're already doing it
because they can and why why would they
react that way because they can
because they have the power to do it and
so they will
when republicans have the power to do it
they just don't
and they make excuses for it and then
when they no longer have the power to do
anything
that's when they pretend that if they
only did have the power again
this time they would do something
okay number four a treasure trove of
newly unsealed
cia records from the daily mail of newly
unsealed cia records has revealed
chilling accounts of hundreds of ufo
sightings across the globe dating back
to the 1950s
along with international intelligence
agencies efforts to understand them
the xxx dossier with
nearly 3 000 pages of documents about
unidentified aerial phenomena
uh was published on the black vault
website last week that's what they call
unidentified aerial phenomena phenomena
uap they use that instead of ufo you're
not gonna fool us government we
know what you're doing um
thousands of paranormal paranormal
enthusiasts have already started pouring
through the collection of more than 700
individual documents according to black
vault's founder
john greenwald the cia reports that the
files account for its entire collection
of declassified uap
intel uh i'm just reading through this
as you are to get to where's the good
stuff maybe i should have read this
before i went on the air
says russian airliner crew um so just
some examples of some of the stuff now
there's thousands of pages
and no one's been through all of it yet
so maybe the smoking gun as it were
uh is is in there somewhere but
it says russian airliner crew describes
coming within
50 kilometers of a yellow disk shooting
beams of light in belarus in
1985. so that's one um
bunch of stuff from russia in the 80s of
weird sightings a swedish pilot and
flight mechanic spotted a completely
unorthodox metallic object
flying at the speed of sound outside
stockholm in 1953.
uh a cia report from 19 from april 1954
includes three newspaper articles about
a purported ufo sighting five months
earlier in sweden
okay so a lot of this is disappointing
this is depressing this is almost as
depressing as the ravens loss
this is just a bunch there's a bunch of
rehash reheated material right now
maybe the good stuff is in there like i
said it is a lot it's a lot of stuff
it's a lot of
information and there have been a lot of
sightings like this but really
what you always have to do right if you
want to decide if you believe something
or not
um believe a claim such as the claim
that ufos exist
ufos exist as an alien actual alien
spacecraft exist and have visited the
earth so if you wanna if you wanna judge
that claim you have to judge the
evidence
the available evidence against
what you expect the evidence would be if
it were true
which is a very unscientific process but
that's kind of the way you have to do it
right
because there is there's a lot of
evidence this does count as evidence
all these claims these eyewitness
supposed eyewitness accounts we've got
thousands and thousands of them
some of them more impressive than others
we've got some video you know
and there's no denying that that is
evidence of ufos
now whether it's compelling evidence to
you is really going to depend on whether
or not you think that if ufos were
really visiting the earth
is this the kind of evidence we would
have or would we have something far more
compelling
and um you could make the argument that
you know if if ufos if aliens were
coming to earth and they didn't want to
be detected this is probably about what
you would
get yeah yeah if they wanted to land and
make a big show of it then we'd all know
that and that there'd be pretty firm
evidence of that but outside of that if
they don't want to be detected then
probably what you'd end up with are a
bunch of random sightings like this
a few pieces of video that are kind of
compelling but that's it
so in other words i go back to my
original assumption speaking of sticking
with our original assumptions that ufos
are real okay
um five from politico at least three
trump family members are either
considering runs for office or being
urged to do so according to
well-connected gop operatives and trump
family allies
uh top party officials say that uh lara
trump wife of the president's son
eric is actively contemplating a run for
the senate north carolina
uh the president's eldest son don jr is
eyeing a future in politics as well
but then it goes to this is what i'm
really focusing on it says
and this is this is politico so of
course grains of salt and all that but
it says the newest and most buzzed-about
possibility however surrounds the
president's daughter ivanka
the senior white house advisor is set to
decamp to florida after her father's
present
presidency comes to a close and though
talk of her launching a primary
challenge
to senator marco rubio has given off the
faint whiff of political fanfic
in reality trump officials say there
have been machinations behind the scenes
one person in contact with the president
said that jared kushner is viewed as
working single-mindedly to protect and
promote his wife's political career
can i just tell you right now and i will
start this movement
unapologetically um i am hashtag never
ivanka
there's there's no reason why we should
be talking about ivanka trump
the left-wing democrat daughter of the
president
there's no reason why we should be
talking about her for political office
and and i'm really not sure where her
base of support is supposed to be
because
because she has trump at the end of her
name she's automatically hated by like
half of the country
and that's not going to change so that's
that's 50 of the electorate that's
out the window right away because of her
last name and then what about the other
half well
yeah there there's gonna be a certain
portion of people who love trump so much
that they would embrace a trump monarchy
and uh
and uh you know they're fine with the
political you know the political dynasty
and hey if it's trump i like it
but that's a minority i i think the
majority of trump supporters and
conservatives generally are going to
look at this and say well she's but
she's
a democrat she's left-wing she we don't
we don't share the same ideas at all
why would i vote for her just because
your daddy was the president that
doesn't qualify you for
any political office at all
so it seems like she is uniquely
positioned
to be hated by almost everybody
that's that's just my political analysis
of this
i mean what do i know i could be wrong
that's the way it seems to me
and i'll also say that that just general
principle here
i think political dynasties are they are
honestly the most un-american thing you
can
possibly conceive of now unfortunately
they're also common in america so i call
them un-american but in another
in another sense they are very american
because they've happened a lot we
we know of recent political dynasties
bush clinton et cetera
um but they are in spirit the most
they're what we tried to get away from
one of the reasons we have this country
is to get away from this uh the fact
that you're
related to a person in power doesn't
mean that you should also be in power
especially if you're ivanka trump all
right you know owning a pet is not all
just fun and games it's also
responsibility if you have a pet then
you have a responsibility to care for it
even if it's not your pet but you're
living in the same house
that's in my case i my my wife's cat i
i am um i have to room with my wife's
cat they
said there's a guest in my house and
what i found is that
even i am in a position where i have to
take care of the cat even if it's not my
cat
and that's why it's so great to have
petsmart from the beginning of the
pandemic petsmart has remained open
making sure you can get
everything your pet needs right when you
need it at over 600 convenient locations
petsmart
stores or grooming salons offer digital
check-in curbside drop-off
pickup and contactless payment and now
petsmart offers free same-day delivery
through january 31st so you can get
everything your pet needs right to your
door
right when you need it you can't beat
that petsmart's associates uh
really love pets and they they care for
them and that's a big part of why they
work for
there and if you go to petsmart you can
really tell that's the case petsmart
makes it
safe and easy for you to care for your
pet too online or in stores if you're
interested in contactless shopping
just order online at petsmart.com or on
the petsmart app and
enjoy easy curbside pickup or free same
day delivery
through january 31st get everything your
pet needs go to petsmart.com for more
details
again that's petsmart.com for more
details
and also you know last thursday was a
big day for the daily wire as we have
made our entrance into the entertainment
content space with our first feature
film run hide fight
it's a movie that you know you know i've
been telling you everyone here at the
dilly wire has been telling you that
it's a really effective thriller
and uh just a really solid really good
movie you don't have to believe us just
go
go look at look at what the people are
saying the people have spoken
and um in fact i want to rot in tomatoes
and the last i checked there was
something like you know you go to raw
tomatoes you can see what the critics
are saying versus what people are saying
and it's something like general audience
reviews like 95
and then the critics give it a 14 grade
and anytime you see a disparity like
that you
first of all you know it's going to be a
good movie and you know there's a reason
why the critics are giving it a bad
review and it's not because of the
quality of the content
it could be that you know they don't
like the fact that daily wire has
anything to do with it
but um that's why you need to check out
this movie if you aren't a member yet
use promo code rhf to get 25
off that's rhf for 25 off please be
aware this film
is not political it is intense it's for
mature audiences only
and uh so it's not a it's not a movie
you sit down and watch with your kids
but we picked this movie after hollywood
refused to
uh critics may have given it a 14 rating
that's right here on rotten tomatoes
but we're receiving positive responses
from thousands of of people since the
premiere last thursday
so now is your chance we're excited to
bring you great stories that hollywood
refuses to tell and we hope you'll join
us to become a member today at
dailywire.com
remember you get 25 off when you use
promo code
rhf so go watch the movie now and
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our first cancellation of the
week we'll be devoting the coveted
monday cancellation to bill
hanagi or hanaj i'm not really sure how
to pronounce it let's just go with
handigy
he's a professor at harvard t.h chan
school of public health he's one of the
many prestigious
public health experts that we've heard
so much about but like many other public
health experts he seems to
struggle with the health and expert part
of that job he's pretty good at being
public though he's got that down
but i don't know about the rest of it as
such he tweeted this week at a picture
of himself looking sweaty and haggard in
a face mask with the caption
yes i wore a mask while running earlier
so he went running with a mask on and
then he stopped and took a picture and
bragged about it
uh hannigh's also made tv appearances to
brag about wearing a mask while running
here he is on a show
in i assume ireland uh and here's what
he had to say listen
so if we're outside we're traditionally
told we don't need to wear a mask as
much we're not
at as much risk but if we're out for
example exercising running jogging
should we be wearing masks i think
that's a really great point
you're absolutely right that the risk of
transmission outdoors
is much much lower than it is indoors
this virus loves it indoors
but if you are going to be outdoors then
it's quite sensible to take a mask with
you if you're out jogging you can take
it down and pull it up if you see
anybody
you should take it like think of it like
this you wouldn't leave the house
without your wallet your car keys or
your phone
try not leaving the house without a mask
what about convincing people to do that
because we see
some level of resistance wearing masks
whilst exercising is
is it it's a big step is it not
well i can tell you personally that i
run over a mile on a regular basis
wearing a mask and it doesn't really
cause me a great deal of bother the
other the other thing i need to say here
is that
if we can persuade people to do it
that's great the more people we can
persuade the better
because these variants are more
transmissible we do need to do more to
stop them
and to you know we have to race the
virus in order to get as many people
vaccinated as possible
and anybody who can do anything to help
by wearing a mask for instance
is doing something to help that uh
anything you can do to help
is doing something to help did you get
that that's good advice
now in a thread on twitter hanagi
further defended his choice to wear a
mask while running outdoors and his
argument essentially boils down to two
points number one
he says there's still some risk of
contracting or spreading covet outside
so it's smart to wear the mask and
number two
wearing the mask is a show of solidarity
with other mask wearers
he really said this it's a show of
solidarity so let's deal with these
points one at a time first
there's still a risk outside so better
safe than sorry okay well the problem
here the problem with
nearly all of the arguments presented in
defense of nearly all of the
anti-covered measures
is that they do not acknowledge the
risks on the other side they act as
though
the person taking these precautions is
playing with house money basically like
there's no risk at all inherent in the
precaution itself
most obvious example is with the
lockdowns well better to do the safest
thing and shut everybody everything down
yes well the problem is that there's a
real cost to that decision there's real
risks involved it may not actually be
the safest thing
that's the point it's like saying better
to do the safest thing and fire a gun
into that dark room in case there's a
burglar in there
now yes that strategy could
theoretically work but there are a whole
lot of ways that it could go very wrong
and you have to factor that into your
equation
with the mask the question is this what
is the actual risk
of spreading or contracting covid while
you run outside
and maybe come within a few feet of
other humans for a second or two while
you pass by them
and what is the risk to your health when
you put something across your face
while engaged in strenuous exercise now
you have to simply determine which poses
the greater risk
this is how you conduct a risk
assessment you need all the endpoints
it inputs you can't possibly come to the
right conclusion if you're only
accounting for risk from one direction
and as far as that goes the world health
organization has this to say quote
this is what they say fact people should
not wear masks while exercising as masks
may reduce the ability to breathe
comfortably sweat can make the mask
become wet more quickly which makes it
difficult to breathe and promotes the
growth of microorganisms
the important preventive measure during
exercise is to maintain physical
distance of at least one meter from
others
now if i could translate here and
simplify wearing a mask while exercising
is gross
disgusting you are breathing in your own
sweat and bodily fumes you are
saturating a piece of cloth
with your perspiration and then
breathing through it
see i actually don't need the world
health health organization to tell me
that that's unhealthy
i know it's unhealthy because i
understand a basic health rule
i'm not a doctor okay but i'm pretty
sure this is actually like
the number one health rule it's right
this is it
breathing is good you need to be able to
breathe
things that hinder breathing are usually
bad
and if that thing is a face soaked is a
is a
is a face muzzle soaked in your own
bodily fluids it's especially bad
and his second point about wearing a
mask for solidarity is is so dumb that
it probably doesn't require refutation
but i will say this i speaking of
solidarity i would rather show
solidarity with people who are
not paranoid lunatics i want to show
solidarity with people who are
willing to stroll down the street
without a mask people who have at least
the minimal courage and boldness to walk
outside their house
and take a breath of fresh air un
unfiltered
now those are the people with which i
claim solidarity
not the cowering hypochondriacs who
treat oxygen like it's radioactive
who can't even walk to their mailbox
without a hazmat suit
so that's why this public health expert
like so many others before him in
accordance with tradition
is canceled i certainly do not have
solidarity
with him so he is canceled that's gonna
do it for uh
the show today thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening have a
great day
[Music]
godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledovsky the
show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is done by nikka geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show the quest
to quash dissenting viewpoints continues
joe biden unveils his radical plans as
the media praise him to the skies that's
today on the ben shapiro i hope you'll
give it a listen